This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. They are hulking but graceful. Human-made whales that float in the air. For over 100 years lighter than air aircraft have fascinated us, and they have this recurring, storing role in our dreams of an alternate reality, of a future that might have been where cargo and passengers traverse the globe in a civilized fashion and dock elegantly on the morey towers on top of art that goes skyscrapers. If you've seen one in real life, it was likely a blimp emblazoned with the good year logo.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。它们庞大而优雅。就像漂浮在空中的人造巨鲸。一个多世纪以来，轻于空气的飞行器一直让我们着迷，它们在我们对另一种现实、对未来的梦想中扮演着反复出现、历久弥新的角色：在那个未来里，货物和乘客以文明的方式穿梭于全球，并优雅地停靠在装饰派艺术摩天大楼顶部的系留塔上。如果你在现实生活中见过它们，那很可能是一艘印有固特异标志的软式飞艇。
A blimp is a non-rigid airship, meaning there's no structure inside the balloon, it's just a balloon. The shape is maintained by the pressure of the lifting gas inside. Then you add a little cockpit and engines and rudders on the outside of that big balloon to make it fly. Today's blimps are basically cute PR novelties, but for around 100 years, lighter than air aircraft were seriously proposed as the perfect design solution for all kinds of problems, even though none of these proposals actually happened. People just couldn't give up on the promise of airships.
软式飞艇是一种非刚性飞艇，这意味着气囊内部没有任何结构，它就只是一个气囊。它的形状是通过内部升力气体的压力来维持的。然后，你在那个大气囊的外部加上一个小型驾驶舱、发动机和方向舵，让它飞起来。今天的软式飞艇基本上只是可爱的公关新奇玩意儿，但在大约100年的时间里，轻于空气的飞行器曾被认真地提议作为解决各种问题的完美设计方案，尽管这些提议最终都没有实现。人们就是无法放弃对飞艇的憧憬。
In the 90s, there was a company called Sky Station. They raised some 4.2 billion or at least solicited it to put 250 antenna equipped airships to deliver internet service. This is Bill Hammack. He's the engineer guy on YouTube in an airship enthusiast. In the 80s, there was the British Antarctic Survey. They revealed a hole in the ozone layer over the South Pole, and so pretty soon a professor suggested sending blimps that dangled electrical wires to zap ozone-eating chemicals. Then in the 70s, they were supposed to help developing nations. Using a hybrid blimp to usher those nations into the 20th century, no need for roads, no need for railroads and tunnels and bridges,
在 90 年代，有一家名为“天空车站”的公司。他们筹集了大约 42 亿美元（或至少进行了募资），计划部署 250 艘配备天线的飞艇来提供互联网服务。我是比尔·哈马克。我是 YouTube 上的“工程师盖伊”（Engineer Guy），也是一名飞艇爱好者。在 80 年代，英国南极调查局成立了。他们发现了南极上空的臭氧层空洞，于是很快有一位教授建议派遣悬挂电缆的飞艇去消灭消耗臭氧层的化学物质。而在 70 年代，它们本应帮助发展中国家。利用混合型飞艇将这些国家带入 20 世纪，不需要公路，不需要铁路、隧道和桥梁，
but just to lift stuff in. In the 1950s and 60s, nuclear-powered airships, with unlimited energy and an unlimited capacity for work were proposed. In the 20s and 30s, they were to fulfill imperial ambitions, both to the Germany and the British. We're looking for that. And the Americans too, they had imperial ambitions in the Philippines. Of all those failed attempts to realize the full potential of airships, it was those imperial rigid airships, heavily developed in the 20s and 30s,
而只需将货物吊运进去。在 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，有人提出了核动力飞艇的设想，它们拥有无限的能量和无限的工作能力。在 20 和 30 年代，它们要实现德国和英国的帝国野心。我们在寻找那种东西。美国人也有过这样的野心，他们在菲律宾。在所有这些实现飞艇全部潜力的失败尝试中，正是那些在 20 和 30 年代得到大力发展的帝国硬式飞艇，
that came the closest to actually changing the world. In an airship, you have a metal framework and that houses gas bags that lift the ship. Those gas bags are arranged in the metal scaffolding like peas in a peepod. And then a cloth cover is stretched over that and that cloth cover is not air tight to protect the gas bags from weather. Underneath the fabric cover are not just gas bags. Because it's not a pressure vessel, they're able to build things inside the airship. Like crew quarters, dining rooms, lounges,
最接近真正改变世界。在一艘硬式飞艇中，你拥有一个金属骨架，里面装有提供升力的气囊。这些气囊像豌豆荚里的豌豆一样排列在金属支架中。然后，一层织物外罩被拉伸覆盖在上面，这层织物外罩并不是气密的，其目的是保护气囊免受天气影响。在织物外罩下面不只有气囊。因为这不是一个压力容器，他们能够在飞艇内部建造各种设施。比如船员舱、餐厅、休息室，
all built into the metal framework. So people move around inside the thing that you might think of as the balloon, but it's not really a balloon. And that structure enables an airship to travel faster than a blimp because the force of the wind, for example, would deform the nose of a blimp, and it also allows the ship to be built much, much bigger. You've maybe heard the term, Derigible, which is the French name for an airship,
全都是直接建造在金属框架里的。所以人们可以在这个你可能会认为是“气囊”的东西内部四处走动，但它其实并不是一个气囊。这种结构使飞艇能够比软式飞艇飞得更快，因为风力（例如）会使软式飞艇的头部变形，而且这也使得飞艇可以建造得比软式飞艇大得多、大得多。你可能听说过“Dirigible”这个词，这是飞艇的法语名称，
or Zeppelin, which is a German company that makes airships. Zeppelin is like the Kleenex or Band-Aid of the airship world. But the proper term, as generic and boring as it sounds, is airship. The most promising, most opulent, rigid airship of its time, and I'm talking about the 1920s here, was Britons R101. The R there stands for Rigid. The rise and dramatic fall of Britons last-grade airship is the primary subject of Bill Hammock's new book called Fatal Flight.
或者叫“齐柏林”，这是一家制造飞艇的德国公司。在飞艇世界里，“齐柏林”就像是“克林耐”（Kleenex）纸巾或“邦迪”（Band-Aid）创可贴那样的代名词。但准确的术语，听起来虽然普通而枯燥，那就是“airship”（飞艇）。那个时代最有前途、最奢华的硬式飞艇——我这里指的是 20 世纪 20 年代——是英国的 R101。其中的 R 代表“Rigid”（硬式）。英国最后一艘顶级飞艇的崛起与戏剧性陨落，是比尔·哈马克名为《致命飞行》（Fatal Flight）的新书的主题。
Spoiler alert. When it comes to the dream of airships dominating the skies, the catastrophic and very public Hindenburg disaster may have been the final nail in the coffin, but it was the crash of R101 that built the coffin. R101 was supposed to connect the global British Empire. It was designed to fly from London to Karachi in five days. That's ten days faster than by sea. Taking a plane that distance took sixteen days because planes had to stop so often to reveal. Airsthips could also carry 30 to 40 times the cargo of airplanes.
剧透预警。当谈到飞艇统治天空的梦想时，灾难性且备受瞩目的“兴登堡”号空难或许是棺材板上的最后一颗钉子，但 R101 的坠毁才是建造这口棺材的关键。R101 本应连接整个大英帝国。它的设计目标是从伦敦飞到卡拉奇，只需五天时间。这比走海路快了十天。乘飞机走这段距离需要十六天，因为飞机必须频繁降落加油。而飞艇的载货量则是普通飞机的 30 到 40 倍。
Airships just made so much sense for an empire whose reach exceeded its grasp. So Great Britain built R101 and R100, which was its sister ship that was supposed to go to Canada in back, as the first two rigid ships in a fleet that would give the crown dominance over the skies to match its centuries-long dominance of the seas. In airship is conceptually quite simple, but it's still an engineering marvel. It's a gargantuan cigar-shaped math equation, balancing lift on one side of the equation and weight on the other, minimizing the weight of the airship was always a challenge.
对于一个雄心勃勃但力不从心的帝国来说，飞艇实在是太合情合理了。于是，英国建造了 R101 以及它的姊妹船 R100（原本计划往返于加拿大），作为舰队中的前两艘硬式飞艇，这支舰队将赋予英国王室对天空的统治权，正如它对海洋长达数个世纪的统治一样。飞艇在概念上相当简单，但它仍然是一个工程奇迹。它是一个巨大的雪茄形数学方程，方程的一边平衡着升力，另一边平衡着重量，将飞艇的重量降到最低一直是一个挑战。
There's that rigid metal framework and that is one of the most difficult parts because that has to be lightweight yet strong. Yet R101 was supposed to match the sturdy luxury of a high-end ocean liner. I mean, I can just picture this white china that was trimmed with royal blue and silver saltcheggers and crystal glasses and small butter dishes.
那个坚固的金属骨架就是最困难的部分之一，因为它既要轻量化又要坚固。然而，R101 还要媲美高端远洋客轮的坚固奢华。我的脑海里甚至能浮现出那些饰有皇家蓝和银边的白瓷餐具、盐瓶、水晶玻璃杯和精致的小黄油碟。
But to allow for those essential refinements, everything else could only have the thinnest veneer of opulence because they needed everything to weigh as little as possible. One person described it when they touched the ceiling as like a piece of stage scenery. All the walls were actually fabric. The pillars and the lounge were made from balsa, covered with metal. The tables were also a balsa, and the chairs were made of the lightest cane. So it was really kind of an illusion,
但为了实现这些必不可少的精致，其他所有东西都只能拥有最薄的一层奢华外表，因为他们需要让每样东西都尽可能轻。曾有人这样描述它：当你触摸天花板时，感觉就像是一块舞台布景。所有的墙壁实际上都是织物。休息室里的柱子是用轻木（balsa）制成的，外面包着金属。桌子也是用轻木做的，椅子则是用最轻的藤条制成的。所以这实际上是一种错觉，
the solidity of the ship, because you just couldn't afford to lift tons and tons of stuff. On the other side of the equation is lift. You get lift from pumping and gas, that's lighter than air. In the case of R101, the gas they used was hydrogen. Well, flammable hydrogen seems like a very poor choice. It was for a commercial airship the only choice. You use hydrogen instead of helium, which is non-fimable, because the purpose of a ship like R101 was to transport cargo. And helium is both heavier and provides
飞艇的坚固感，因为你根本负担不起运送成吨重物的代价。方程的另一边是升力。升力是通过充入比空气轻的气体获得的。就 R101 而言，他们使用的气体是氢气。嗯，易燃的氢气似乎是一个非常糟糕的选择。但对于商业飞艇来说，它是唯一的选择。你使用氢气而不是不可燃的氦气，是因为像 R101 这样的飞艇的目的是运输货物。而氦气既重，又比氢气提供更少的升力。
less lift than hydrogen. What you're interested in is the payload that you can lift. So if you subtract all of the weight that you have to lift, the rigid ship, the gas bags, the water, the personnel, in a ship like R101, if you filled it with helium, you would not have enough lift to lift the ship. The flammability of hydrogen was indeed a concern in airships. But flattin engineers filled it with helium, you would not have enough lift to lift the ship. The flammability of hydrogen was indeed a concern in airships, but flight engineers and crew were habituated to its dangers, much like we're habituated to the dangers of combustion engines today.
你真正关心的是你能举起的有效载荷。因此，如果你减去你必须承载的所有重量——硬式飞艇、气囊、水、人员，在像 R101 这样的飞艇中，如果你给它充氦气，你就没有足够的升力来让飞艇升空。氢气的易燃性在飞艇中确实是一个令人担忧的问题。但如果飞艇工程师给它充氦气，你就没有足够的升力来让飞艇升空。氢气的易燃性在飞艇中确实是一个令人担忧的问题，但飞行工程师和机组人员对它的危险已经习以为常，就像我们今天对内燃机的危险习以为常一样。
They felt that you just take the proper precautions. One engineer pronounced you don't light a match and look in your gas tank and your car when you're driving around with something highly flammable all of the time right now, you get the proper engineering solutions and controls to do it. The other reason why helium wasn't an option on commercial airships was the cost. Helium at that time was produced in the US.
他们觉得只要采取适当的预防措施就行了。一位工程师宣称：你在开车时不会点燃火柴往油箱里看，你现在随时都在驾驶着高度易燃的东西，只要采取适当的工程解决方案和控制措施来处理就行了。商业飞艇不考虑氦气的另一个原因是成本。当时的氦气是在美国生产的。
It comes from natural gas that's required expensive distillation plants and most of the helium is in places like Kansas and Oklahoma and Texas. So they would have to pay for it to be imported into Britain. Instead you can make hydrogen on site very cheaply. Almost one one hundredth of the cost of helium. So that was never really, you know, an option, never really considered.
它来自需要昂贵蒸馏装置的天然气，而且大部分氦气都位于堪萨斯州、俄克拉荷马州和德克萨斯州等地。因此，他们必须支付将其进口到英国的费用。相反，你可以在现场非常便宜地制造氢气。几乎是氦气成本的百分之一。所以这其实从来不是一个选择，也从未被真正考虑过。
The gas bags that contain the hydrogen are their own engineering marvel. It's interesting to me as an engineer to think about the materials they had to make these gas bags because you have a problem in that hydrogen wants to permeate, the small molecule that likes to go through things. So you need something that's very strong, that is impermeable to hydrogen or largely impermeable and that is lightweight. And so they tried things like rubber, gelatin, glycerin, something called viscoose, which is a synthetic fabric, it's coated with latex. But they all
包含氢气的气囊本身就是一项工程奇迹。作为一名工程师，想到他们制作这些气囊所使用的材料，我感到非常有趣，因为你面临着一个问题：氢气想要渗透，这是一种喜欢穿透物体的微小分子。所以你需要一种非常坚固、对氢气不渗透（或基本不渗透）且轻量化的材料。因此，他们尝试了诸如橡胶、明胶、甘油之类的东西，还有一种叫做粘胶纤维（viscose）的合成织物，上面涂有乳胶。但它们都
failed when we were another, like the viscoose, if you crumpled it up, you could not uncrevel it, we just crack. So they used, and this stuns me to this day, the intestines of an oxen. And specifically, the oxen intestine, it's lined with a very fine membrane. It's called the seacum. And it's very thin and flexible. And hydrogen siepes only slowly through it. Oxen intestines are nearly the perfect material except for the size. The seacum of an ox is about 30 inches by six inches, so a little over a square foot. And yet one of those gas bags, if you laid it out, is 30,000 square feet.
由于这样或那样的原因失败了，比如粘胶纤维，如果你把它揉成一团，你就无法把它展平，它会直接裂开。于是他们使用了——这至今仍让我震惊——牛的肠子。具体来说，是牛的肠子，里面内衬着一层非常细的膜。它被称为盲肠（cecum）。它非常薄且有弹性。氢气穿过它的速度非常慢。牛肠几乎是完美的材料，除了尺寸之外。一头牛的盲肠大约是 30 英寸乘 6 英寸，也就是稍微多一平方英尺。然而，如果你把其中一个气囊摊开，它的面积是 30,000 平方英尺。
And so to create one of these gas bags, you would use 50,000 of these entrails or so. In fact, there's about a million and a half oxen and test lines that were needed to create the 15 gas bags for R101. And it was fairly grisly work. They delivered from slaughterhouses in Argentina, at least some of the animals,
因此，要制造其中一个气囊，你需要使用大约 50,000 个这样的内脏。事实上，制造 R101 的 15 个气囊大约需要 150 万个牛肠。这是一项相当毛骨悚然的工作。它们从阿根廷的屠宰场运来，至少有一部分动物是这样，
barrels of these guts, and then they would scrape them and go through this long process to prepare them and eventually to glue them together. And to answer your question, 50,000 oxen testants, even once cured and treated to make them into gas backs,
一桶桶的内脏，然后工人们要刮洗它们，经历漫长的过程来处理，最终把它们粘合在一起。来回答你的问题，50,000 个牛肠，即使经过硫化处理制成气囊后，
do kind of stink. They did. They did. Apparently, if you were up in the airship, you would smell kind of an animal smell did? They did? Apparently, if you were up in the airship, you would smell, you know, kind of an animal smell, a muskety smell also because the cloth cover didn't allow light in. R101 had a few test flights in and around its hanger outside London to great fanfare. In fact, Bill Hemmick surmises that the focus on PR and fanfare,
确实还是有点臭的。确实如此。显然，如果你在飞艇里，你会闻到一种动物的气味。确实如此？是的！显然，如果你在飞艇里，你会闻到一种动物的气味，一种麝香味的气味，这也是因为织物外罩不透光。R101 在伦敦郊外的机库周围进行了一些试飞，引起了巨大的轰动。事实上，比尔·哈马克推测，人们对公关和声势的关注，
rather than more rigorous and deliberative testing, led to the tragedy that was about to come on the ship's first attempted flight to India in 1930. It had left on October 4th, about 6.30 at night, about 54 people on board. Most of them worked for the Royal Airship Works, but some were observers and some were dignitaries. So, traveled across England,
而不是更严谨、审慎的测试，最终导致了这艘飞艇在 1930 年首次飞往印度的尝试中即将发生的悲剧。它于 10 月 4 日晚上 6 点半左右出发，机上大约有 54 人。他们大多数为皇家飞艇厂工作，但也有一些是观察员和政要。因此，它飞越了英国，
traveled across the channel into France, and there were these bruising winds. Wind so fierce that ground speed was only 30 miles per hour or so. And then a few minutes passed too, it was about 40 miles or 64 kilometers north of Paris. And it kind of chopped through the turbulent air flying at about 1200 feet but moving up and down a couple of hundred feet and the top cover ripped open. The top cover was weak, it was one of the weakest parts of the ship. Then at that point the gas bags which are made of these very thin intestines were exposed to rain, the rain pelted the gas bags, there was some decrease in lift, maybe dropped to 500 feet or so, and the control car, and no one knows why, today, signaled for the engine power to be cut off, and of course it lost all dynamic lift at that point,
飞越英吉利海峡进入法国，当时正刮着狂风。风大到地面速度只有每小时 30 英里左右。几分钟过去了，它飞到了巴黎以北约 40 英里或 64 公里处。它在约 1200 英尺的高空中艰难穿过湍流，上下起伏了几百英尺，顶部外罩突然撕裂了。顶部外罩很脆弱，它是飞艇最薄弱的部位之一。就在那时，由这些极薄的肠衣制成的气囊暴露在了雨中，雨水不断拍打着气囊，升力有所下降，可能下降到了 500 英尺左右，控制舱——时至今日也没人知道为什么——发出了切断发动机动力的信号，当然，它在那个时候失去了所有的动态升力，
and it drove nose first to the ground, it slid into a grove of hazel and oak trees, and it burst into flame. There's some debate as to why it burst into flames. Wilhelmic thinks the fire might have been caused by calcium-phosphide flares that were kept in the control car. Those ignite when water hits them. And of course that ignited the hydrogen. At that point, just everything became charred. Only six people survived it. The ground was littered with these, you know, very sad everyday things. I mean, suitcases, fird-lined boots, shard-saving brushes, ten of cigarettes, and there was a taking watch still there, and tens of plums with its juice leaking. And then it was very quiet, and all you could hear was the hiss of the rain as it hit the hot metal and it evaporated.
它一头栽向地面，滑进了一片榛树和橡树林，然后起火燃烧了。关于它为什么起火，目前还有一些争论。比尔·哈马克认为，火灾可能是由存放在控制舱内的磷化钙信号弹引起的。当水接触到它们时，它们就会自燃。当然，这随即点燃了氢气。在那一刻，一切都化为焦炭。只有六个人幸存了下来。地面上散落着这些非常悲伤的日常物品。我是指手提箱、毛皮内衬的靴子、碎掉的剃须刷、一盒盒香烟，那里还有一块仍在走动的怀表，以及几十个流着果汁的李子。随后四周变得极其安静，你唯一能听到的只有雨水打在炽热金属上并蒸发时的嘶嘶声。
The wreckage had barely cooled when the British government halted their airship program for good. It was almost immediate. R100 had flown two Montreal and back, and it was in a shed, and it never flew again. They eventually steamrolled R100, sold some of the parts for scrap, sold some of the people who wanted souvenirs. Even though our 101 was completely destroyed in the French countryside, the burned remains did float in the sky once again, at least for a little while.
残骸甚至还没完全冷却，英国政府就永远叫停了他们的飞艇项目。几乎是立刻进行的。R100 曾飞往蒙特利尔并往返，当时正停在机库里，却再也没有飞过。他们最终用蒸汽压路机碾平了 R100，将部分零件当作废铁卖掉，也卖给了一些想要纪念品的人。尽管 R101 在法国乡村被彻底摧毁，但烧焦的残骸至少在天空中再次漂浮了一小会儿。
Well, the wreckage of that ship was cut up into pieces, shipped back in December to Great Britain and it went to somebody who takes scrap metal. And then apparently, according to a newspaper account, it was sold to the Zeppelin company and they used part of that metal to make the hand in work. Because of the romanticism wrapped up in airships, their flexibility when it comes to moving huge cargo, and the fact that it requires very little infrastructure to support their operation, the hope that airships will make a return
好吧，那艘飞艇的残骸被切成碎片，在 12 月运回了英国，交由一家回收废金属的公司处理。然后显然，根据一家报纸的报道，它被卖给了齐柏林公司，他们用一部分金属制造了“兴登堡”号。由于人们对飞艇抱有的浪漫主义情怀、它们在运输巨型货物方面的灵活性，以及它们运营所需的极少基础设施，人们对飞艇回归的希望
has never gone away. I mean, I get a question a lot. Our airships gonna come back and with new materials. Part of the reason why they don't come back is this fiery disaster-filled legacy, which I am perpetuating right now. What politician wants to vote in an airship and have a crash and somebody said, well, you know, didn't you know about the Hindenburg, right?
从未消逝。我的意思是，我经常被问到一个问题：飞艇会卷土重来并采用新材料吗？它们无法卷土重来的部分原因在于这段充满灾难的传奇历史，而我现在正在不断提起它。哪个政治家愿意投票支持飞艇项目，万一发生坠毁，然后有人会说：“难道你不知道兴登堡号吗？”
No, this isn't quite fair. If you look at something like the Grafseppelin, which was a contemporary of R101 and a predecessor to the Hindenburg, it was in service for nine years across the Atlantic 144 times. 16,000 flight hours, 590 flights, 13,000 passengers, the first aircraft ever to exceed one million flight miles. And circumnavigated the globe in just 21 days. So there is, you know, another history back there
不，这其实并不公平。如果你看看像“格拉夫·齐柏林”号这样的飞艇——它是 R101 的同时代产品，“兴登堡”号的前身——它服役了九年，横跨大西洋 144 次。16,000 个飞行小时，590 次飞行，13,000 名乘客，它是历史上第一架飞行里程超过一百万英里的飞行器。并且仅用了 21 天就完成了环球航行。所以，你知道，还有另一段历史
that says that these things can be made and can be made well. At this point, the airplane has had a centuries worth of development and efficiency, speed and safety so that the need for the airship has been largely eliminated. But it passed as precedent. Some enterprising engineer is an arumphant of entericapolis right now trying to convince them
表明这些东西是可以被制造出来的，而且可以造得很好。到了这个地步，飞机已经经历了长达一个世纪的发展，在效率、速度和安全性上都得到了提升，以至于飞艇的需求在很大程度上已经被淘汰了。但它作为先例留了下来。一些雄心勃勃的工程师正是不知疲倦地向当局游说，试图说服他们
that giant airships are the solution to some pressing world problem. In the meantime, the airship will continue on in science fiction stories as this quick and easy visual cue that were in a world that's like ours but somehow more wondrous. One of the most memorable pieces of audio of all time and my favorite video by the engineer guy right after this. and my favorite video by the engineer guy right after this. When the Hindenburg crashed and burned in a New Jersey field in 1937, a reporter from Chicago radio station WLS named Herbert Morrison was there. His real-time reaction to the disaster that was unfolding in front of him became one of the most memorable recordings in broadcast history. A couple people on staff here had never heard it before which totally
巨型飞艇是解决某些紧迫世界问题的方案。与此同时，飞艇将继续存在于科幻小说中，作为一个迅速而简单的视觉符号，暗示我们身处一个既熟悉却又更加奇妙的世界。史上最难忘的音频片段之一，以及我最喜欢的“工程师盖伊”视频，就在这之后。以及我最喜欢的“工程师盖伊”视频，就在这之后。1937 年，当“兴登堡”号在新泽西州的一片田野里坠毁并起火时，芝加哥广播电台 WLS 的记者赫伯特·莫里森（Herbert Morrison）正在现场。他对眼前正在展开的灾难的实时反应，成为了广播史上最令人难忘的录音之一。这里有两名工作人员以前从未听过这个录音，这让我大吃一惊，所以我很想在这里播放它。你可能听不清所有的词，但莫里森的情绪却清晰而强烈地传达了出来。
shocked me so I wanted to play it here. You might not be able to make out all the words but Morrison's emotions come through loud and clear. running the rain again, the rain has cracked up a little bit. They packed motors with a ship, are just holding it just enough to keep it from... It's right in the flagging. Get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it, get it all the folks between the deserts terrible, this is the one that works your task of being in the wild, they always see this as like 20, all 400, 500 feet into the sky. If a terrific grace, ladies and gentlemen,
雨又下了起来，雨稍微变小了一点。他们把发动机和飞艇连在一起，正勉强支撑着不让它……它就在系留塔里。抓住它，抓住它，抓住它，抓住它，抓住它，抓住它，抓住它，抓……哦，天哪！沙漠中所有的人都太可怕了，这是那个在野外工作的……他们总是把它看作大约 20、400、500 英尺的高空。发生了一场可怕的事故，女士们先生们，
is smoking, it's slaves now, and they claim it's rising to the ground, it's not quite to the morning mass, all the humanity, all the furniture, it's screaming at us. I don't do it. I tell the entire people,. I don't do it. I tell them I'm talking to people. And they're all there.
正在冒烟，它现在裂开了，他们说它正在坠落地面，还没有完全到系留塔，所有的人性，所有的家具，都在对我们尖叫。我做不到。我告诉所有人……我做不到。我告诉他们我正在跟人们说话。他们都在那里。
I can't talk, ladies and gentlemen. Honestly, just like they are now talking like they do. And everybody can hardly breathe in the pocket. They're screaming, lady, I'm sorry. Honestly, I can hardly breathe. I'm the devil inside, while I cannot see it. I'm totally unstable. I can't. I can't. I can't. I'm going to have to stop for a minute because I have lots of opportunities.
我说不出话来，女士们先生们。老实说，就像他们现在这样说话。每个人在口袋里都几乎喘不过气来。他们在尖叫，女士，我很抱歉。老实说，我几乎喘不过气来。我内心备受煎熬，但我看不见。我彻底崩溃了。我不能。我不能。我不能。我得停一会儿，因为我有很多机会。
I've worked together, I've ever worked with it. That radio recording was later paired with newsreel footage of the disaster. 36 of the 97 people onboard the Hindenburg died. When you see the footage of the burning airship, the fact that 61 people survived seems like a miracle. As I mentioned in my introduction to Bill Hammock on YouTube, he's known as Engineer Guy, and I would be remiss if I didn't point you toward his fantastic video on the ingenious design of the aluminum beverage can, which is for my money, the greatest video on YouTube. It is 11 1.5 minutes of everyday design
我们齐心协力，我从未和它一起工作过。这段广播录音后来与这场灾难的新闻片剪辑在了一起。“兴登堡”号上的 97 人中有 36 人丧生。当你看到这艘燃烧的飞艇的镜头时，61 人幸存下来这一事实简直像是个奇迹。正如我在 YouTube 上对比尔·哈马克的介绍中所提到的，他被称为“工程师盖伊”，如果我不向你推荐他关于铝制饮料罐巧妙设计的精彩视频，那我就太失职了，在我看来，这是 YouTube 上最伟大的视频。那是 11 分半钟的日常设计
and engineering glory. I love it. Here's a little audio sample. Why is there a tab on the end of the can? It seems a silly question. How else would you open it? But originally, cans didn't have tabs. Very early steel cans were called flat tops
与工程荣耀。我太喜欢它了。这里有一个简短的音频样本。为什么罐子端部会有一个拉环？这似乎是个愚蠢的问题。不然你该怎么打开它？但最初，罐子是没有拉环的。早期的钢罐被称为平顶罐，
for pretty obvious reasons. You'll use a special opener to puncture a hole to drink from and a hole to vent. In the 1960s, the pole tab was invented so that no opener was needed. You can find links to Bill's videos and his book on the R101 on his website, engineerguide.com 99% invisible is Avery Trouffman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sharif Yusif, Taren Masa, composer, Sean Rial, digital director, Kurt Colstead, senior editor, Delaney Hall, senior producer, Katie Mingle, and me, Roman Mars.
原因显而易见。你需要使用专门的开罐器来刺出一个孔以便饮用，再刺一个孔用于通气。在 20 世纪 60 年代，拉环被发明了出来，这样就不需要开罐器了。你可以在比尔的网站 engineerguide.com 上找到他的视频以及关于 R101 的书籍的链接。99% Invisible 的成员包括埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、谢里夫·尤西夫（Sharif Yusif）、塔伦·马萨（Taren Masa），作曲家肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial），数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead），资深编辑德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall），资深制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle），以及我，罗曼·马斯。
We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are part of Radio Atopia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all a podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or one Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心广播街（Radio Row）。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Utopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最好、最具创新性的节目的集体。我们由像你这样的听众资助。你可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（@Roman Mars），或@节目组（@99PI），也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。
But we have very fun pictures and diagrams of the airships on our website. They're even more amazing than you can picture in your head at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在官网上发布了非常有趣的飞艇图片和图表。它们比你脑海中想象的还要惊人，网址是 99PI.org。Radio Utopia。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。